[Music]
what do you think the city of st. Louis
mints to the International chess stage
but each year becomes more and more
prominent the grand chest tour is
expanding there's so many more
international events bringing players
from all over the world top players st.
Louis has become for sure the capital of
chess in the world
maybe not the rock capital of chess but
one of the capitals I guess I mean
together with probably Moscow and some
other place it's very strong
mmm I gotta say chess City so I'm happy
I'm here when you hear some Louis you
kind of at least I think about chess
it's really great but what son Louis has
become for chess I see a lot of chess
activity a lot of events a lot of kids
playing here so it's wonderful here
there are many really interesting events
Grantchester is quite a nice idea I was
following the Kent's Cup among other
tournaments but also many others a
championship us ownership but mainly the
sink fold Cup these days where all the
top players are impeding beyond that
there are also a lot of European players
who try to play the norm tournaments as
well and just in general it's it's a
great atmosphere and it's great to see
all the things that have happened here
in st. Louis over the last ten years I
guess ten or eleven years Rick fin do
you think they'll have really done a lot
to support Jeff here it's the thirst of
in the sport of where great American
chess players come if the only reason
why American Jeff is booming right now
any tournament you play in Europe
wherever it is people have heard about
the chess club's classic Center in st.
Louis this is my very first time in st.
Louis but of course I was watching many
of the tournaments and events taking
place here just when I got this tool you
know looking around the place a little
bit I was very familiar is Blanco I
believe that people are getting to know
st. Louis and getting to respect the
effort puts in st. Louis is absolutely
set an example for what chest should be
all over the world will be you guys have
both hosted the best tournaments in the
world as well as put chess as far as I
know into every single school in the st.
Louis area and this is
is a dream come true for a chess player
of any level be a professional or
someone who just enjoys the game and I
think the rest are all would be do a
great job to follow st. Louis example
[Music]